first night at the old house at least
stays in her old room where most of the
supernatural activity is focused and a
ghostly figure sneaks up on her but when
she turns she sees her dad's old uniform
I believe that this was Ki face because
when she goes to touch the set of keys
in the jacket pocket she gets a little
static shot just like what we saw when
he face touched the doorknob in her
childhood there are also other examples
of Chief face having a shock to the
touch going forward like his other
attributes I think there's symbolism
here as well static electricity can be
built up when materials rub together
causing electrons to build up in an
object when you touch that object you
may get a static shot you can't see the
electrons when they're built up on the
surface but they are there waiting to be
accessed it's a lot like how Elise
represses her painful childhood memories
but when she revisits the house and
comes across keyface the memories rush
back and she's in for a painful shot